pourquoi vous vous manifestiez en tant
que travailleuse du sexe une
manifestation pour contre la réforme des
retraites et vous avez le temps
oui mais c'est important parce que
j'étais là pour dire que les peaux aussi
demandent l'accès le droit à la retraite
et on veut être juste considérer et
prise
dans la lutte ouvrière en fait vous avez
choisi depuis les seins nus
c'est un signe de protestation c'est
c'est
politiquement Corre et politique en tant
que femme trans et [__] mon corps est
politique et je m'en sers comme outil de
militantisme vous voulez faire passer un
message voilà comme ça tout à fait voilà
donc il y a cet homme qui va vous
approcher et vous accoucher qu'est-ce
qui vous a dit il voulait savoir en fait
si mes seins étaient siliconés ou pas
parce que il se demandait si j'étais
trans en fait quand il m'a touché je lui
ai dit c'était pas permis de toucher en
fait et après je vais cracher dessus
j'attendais quoi de la justice là pour
là-dessus quelle façon de travail et
qu'elle me reconnaisse victime de cette
agression sexuelle en fait